in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Bradley
is here hey Bradley idea bug right
better than I deserve sir how are you
I'm doing fantastic good were you from
Tulsa Oklahoma
very cool welcome to Nashville thank you
and here to do an in-person dead free
scream no other way to do it I love it
love it how much have you paid officer I
paid all 41,000 in 13 months and then 45
in the six years prior to that okay very
cool and your range of income in that 13
months 13 months it was 56 to 67,000
very cool what do you do for a living I
do pipeline or CAD work for a pipeline
engineering firm good good great job
cool good for you so what kind of debt
was the 41,000 the 41 was all student
loans okay yeah all right and what
happened 13 months ago that puts you on
that journey well I just finished paying
off the kind of the lesser portion of
what I owed Sallie Mae mm-hmm and I kind
of had my own plan going but it got to a
point where I began to put my numbers or
my plan to what was left which was the
41 and it's going to take me another
three or four years to do it
mm-hmm and I was like something's got to
change I'll be 30 by the time that
happens and so just kind of over the
course of that particular time I was
looking for different plans and I came
across you actually had some friends who
were going through financial peace prior
to their marriage and so that's where I
kind of get introduced to you very cool
yeah very cool so what have you done
over 13 months to pay off 41,000 making
only 67 that's that seriously beans and
rice right there it was beans and rice
sandwiches and spaghetti a lot a lot of
spaghetti
I hate spaghetti it's now officially
broke people food in whereas like legit
broke people food I got rid of the pasta
that's still left over oh no I had it
was funny because I just got my savings
account up to about 10 grand when they
came across you I've been trying to do
that for years and then you start
telling me I take it down to one and I'm
looking at you like you're crazy wasn't
I just hit like I just finally got there
and this guy wants me to give it up
exactly and then I had that plus my tax
return just come in which was around
like 4500 she got $14,000 boost yeah so
I took that 14,000 immediately through
to the loans and
if I'm going to give a 14 grand to do
this I'm going all the way yeah so I cut
off the 401k cut down a lifestyle got on
a budget a more strict budget and just
got after it very cool yeah what was the
thing you cut that was the hardest to
cut in here budget hardest was cut was
going out and telling myself no you
can't go get chick-fil-a whenever you
wanna get chick-fil-a it was staying
home night after night eating spaghetti
or sandwiches for dinner um not going to
my sister's birthday party she went she
was in she was a freshman at the
University of Central Oklahoma and the
last year I couldn't go because I was on
a budget and I couldn't spend that kind
of money
mm-hmm so I cut lifestyle cut that kind
of stuff out and just like I said got
after it day after day man you were on
it oh yeah the good news is you had
nobody to control but you the bad news
is you had nobody holding you
accountable
yeah well I I went through FPU at some
points I did have an accountability
there okay but just like you said yeah
that's kind of the blessing in it is I
didn't have to control somebody else it
was just me but at the same time you
feel alone because you're in it just by
yourself yeah so that that was kind of a
tough deal to do very cool who was the
most encouraging as you went along uh I
I can't necessarily point out one
individual I mean certainly people who
are in my FPU class but mostly it was
you listening to the show day in day out
and just kind of keeping myself
encouraged to let let him reminding me
of what days like this would be like
being able to come to Nashville and go
eat where I want to eat because all
right so I'm gonna go eat I want to eat
yeah that's it now any no spaghetti
tonight spaghetti I'm having ribs ha ha
I like it that's good oh yeah there's
some good ribs around here you should do
well with that
made my mouth water all right I go eat
with you but I'm going to Raleigh sure
okay gotta be in Raleigh in a few
minutes thank you well uh now those four
thousand people probably don't think so
they don't mind they don't mind they'll
put it all I just say I was having ribs
with Bradley you guys your tickets you
bought deck with them yeah right that
would work yeah okay so who made fun of
you while you were doing this you know
nobody made fun of me I did get a remark
about not having an iPhone which I
thought was funny because I own my phone
and I doubt they do but other than that
nobody really made fun of me
at all so hmm okay very cool
good very good so uh how old are you 27
okay so 27 year old single guy or single
gal out there listening wondering if
they can actually do this Dave Ramsey
that snowball stuff what do you tell
them the key to paying off forty-one
thousand dollars and thirteen months is
I had to redefine what progress look
like to me progress was seeing the email
confirmation that they accepted my
payment and then seeing the the actual
number go down seeing the change or the
difference of whatever it was yesterday
to today but that only happens once a
month or once a week depending on how
you're making payments so the other days
just feel like you're not making
progress so what I had to start telling
myself was look every time you stick to
your plan every day you do that you just
made progress mm-hmm at the beginning of
the month you did your budget you should
be able to put this much towards your
debt well every day you stick to your
plan you keep that number intact mmm so
that's what I had to do I had to
redefine what progress look like mmm
that's good that's really good
very profound excellent way to go
Bradley thank you you did it you're here
man yeah it's happened how does it feel
it feels great it's it's it's relaxing
it's peaceful
I I've noticed a change I'm just happier
that that sense of oppression that goes
along with having to os1 money with
having someone's hand on your wallet
whether you see it there or not that's
not there and so I'm just a little bit
more carefree than then I typically used
to be so that I'm enjoying quite a bit
very cool
good for you all right Bradley to Tulsa
Oklahoma
$41,000 paid off in 13 months savings
tax return and spaghetti that's how I
did it fifty six thousand dollars up to
sixty seven thousand a year count it
down let's hear a debt free screen let's
do it three two one
love it that's how it's done right there
baby love it love it love it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and say you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind